bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
ici au parlement européen à bruxelles
dans cette émission nous allons parler
du gaspillage alimentaire nous allons
aller à londres voir ce que les
britanniques font en la matière et à
paris kathia gilder recevra guillaume
garot il est le ministre français
délégué à l'agroalimentaire mais la
question de la semaine c'est le budget
européen
les responsables européens sont en train
de s'écharper sur la question alors
l'europe va-t-elle dans le mur
c'est la question posée par nora hamadi
en période de disette voici les 27 à
table pour discuter gros sous avec au
menu une question car cayenne comment
boucler le budget de l'union quand tous
les états se serre la ceinture
derrière les sourires de circonstance
ça grince entre les partisans d'une
augmentation de l' enveloppe et les
autres les autres
david cameron entre autres comme à son
habitude le premier ministre britannique
a mis les pieds dans le lard sa
proposition un gel du budget une
position refusée par son propre
parlement qui demande lui une réduction
pure et simple alors comme souvent dans
l'union la situation vire au vaudeville
en gala merkel menace d'annuler un
sommet extraordinaire consacré à la
question y entame une tournée européenne
pour tenter un déblocage
pendant ce temps dans les couloirs on
s'agite on palabre on tergiverse 50
milliards 100 milliards c'est la chasse
au rabais sur le budget européen mais un
budget de djata l'heure il faut relancer
l'économie quelle idée
en même temps au sud de bruxelles les
grecs entament leur énième grève
générale contre un énième budget
d'austérité dans l'indifférence générale
alors ce budget il va dormir alors nous
sommes sur ce plateau avec alain
lamassoure bonjour bonjour vous êtes
député européen vous êtes président de
la commission du budget ici au parlement
européen il va y avoir un sommet dans
quelques jours un sommet européen ici à
bruxelles
est-ce que ce sommet qui sera consacrée
justement au budget européen est ce que
ce sommet va déboucher sur un accord
mais je souhaite qu'ils débouchent sur
un accord soit ce sommet soit le suivant
ça sera une négociation difficile sur un
accord qui est de l'europe avancer
l'europe un budget famille européenne un
budget familial qui est tout petit qui
représente 1% du produit intérieur brut
européen environ 130 milliards d'euros
30 à 40 % du budget national français
ce budget pour des raisons historiques
est consacré pour 40% à aider les
agriculteurs en cas de la politique
agricole commune pour 40% aux
investissements régionaux du fonds
régionaux pour 10% la politique
étrangère et 10% seulement aux
investissements d'avenir à l'innovation
à la recherche aux grandes
infrastructures de transports et des
communications qui sont évidemment les
actions dont nous avons besoin pour
retrouver la compétitivité et la
croissance
depuis la crise de la dette depuis trois
ans les dirigeants européens ont déployé
les efforts pour aider les pays en
difficulté à sortir de la crise le
malade est à l'hôpital il est sous
perfusion à travers le fond qu'on
appelle mécanisme européen de stabilité
le balad a pris des engagements
désormais de mieux s'alimenter et d'être
à la diète
c'est le traité budgétaire bon mais
maintenant la question qui va se poser
quand le malade va sortir de l'hôpital
c'est comment on en refait un athlète
capable sur la scène internationale de
lutter à armes égales avec l'athlète
chinois américains c est ça
c'est le rôle du budget européen si nous
savons faire en sorte que un maximum de
crédits soit consacrée à une solution
d'avenir si on reprend votre votre
allégorie c'est que les états européens
n'ont pas du tout envie de payer pour
l'hôpital ils ont pas du tout envie de
payer ensuite pour l'athlète voilà alors
vous avez mis le doigt sur le défaut du
budget européen
c'est qu'il n'a pas de ressources
propres le budget européen est financé
par les vingt-sept budgets nationaux
c'est exactement comme si il y avait 27
contribuables pour financer le budget
européen
c'est un système qui aboutit à l'impasse
actuelle puisque les vingt-sept budget
nationaux sont quasiment ruinées et donc
aucun ministre du budget ne veut
augmenter ses impôts ou sa dette pour
augmenter sa participation au budget
européen
c'est pourquoi le parlement européen se
bat depuis plusieurs années et est
arrivé à faire reconnaître le principe
selon lequel les dépenses européennes
doivent être financées par des
ressources européennes
il faut couper le lien entre budgets
nationaux et budget européen
aulas en est enfin on n'en est pas
encore on n est pas encore là et ont
encore une fois dans quelques jours il
ya ce sommet penser que à la fin de ce
sommet qui pourrait d'ailleurs durer
visiblement trois jours je crois qu'on
tient un sommet à trois chemise parce
que il durera trois jours
est ce qu'on pense qu'il y aura un
accord ou est ce que les dirigeants vont
se séparer sur un constat d'échec
je suis pas pronostiqueur sportif moi ce
qui m'intéresse c'est que les dirigeants
se comportent en dirigeants et non pas
en sous secrétaires d'état au budget et
que chacun se demande le président
français la chancelière allemande le le
le les premiers ministres italien
espagnol et les autres dans cette
période où sortons de la crise où nous
devons retrouver la compétitivité ou
pour relancer la croissance en europe
nous avons besoin d'atteindre une masse
critique pour un certain nombre de
grands investissements d'avenir qu'est
ce que nous attendons du budget européen
quel doit être son montant à quoi on le
consacre et comment on le finance et sur
la manière de trouver des ressources
propres il ya deux propositions sur la
table qu'on va examiner dont on va
débattre
premièrement la taxe sur les
transactions financières il ya
maintenant une moitié de pays qui sont
tout à fait favorable à ce qu'on crée
taxe sur les transactions financières
qui pourrait venir alimenter directement
du budget européen est une nouvelle
forme de tva qui pour un taux très
faible pourrait également alimenter le
budget européen
à ce moment là nous pourrons trouver des
moyens de financement
si ça n'est pas le cas et si chacun se
contentent d'essayer de minimiser sa
contribution aux saunas ce qu'il rate
deux pays et de maximiser ce qu'il en
retire par exemple traditionnellement la
france se bat uniquement sur
l'agriculture
tant mieux pour nos agriculteurs sauf
que l'enjeu des dix ans qui viennent
si on veut que la france retrouve sa
compagnie thé c'est pas simplement
l'agriculture la position française
justement une question est ce que la
position française est clair aujourd'hui
elle l'était avec nicolas sarkozy on
était d'accord ou pas d'accord mais elle
était clair est ce qu'avec françois
hollande vous ici à bruxelles au
parlement européen vous comprenez sur le
budget qui est la position française
elle est incompréhensible
elle est complètement contradictoire et
donc à l'heure où nous parlons je
souhaite que ça change
à l'heure où nous parlons elle ne pèse
pas que dit la france il faut geler le
budget européen jusqu'en 2020 ce que
disait nicolas sarkozy déjà ses lacets
la suite ce que des années classement je
dirais il était dans une période
électorale
aujourd'hui la position de la france
comme de l'allemagne comme du premier
britannique sait on gèle jusqu'en 2020
et mais à l'intérieur de ce gène il faut
maintenir l'argent pour l'agriculture il
faut maintenir l'argent pour les régions
puissent toutes les régions françaises
sont dirigées par des socialistes
et puis il faut essayer de faire plus
pour les dépenses d'avenir c'est
totalement contradictoire
je souhaite que la france fasse le bon
choix qui est la priorité à l'avenir
alors vous avez mis le doigt sur un
sujet entre guillemets qui fait mal en
tout cas un programme qui est très
populaire un programme européen très
populaire qui s'appelle erasmus et vous
avez dit il ya quelques jours que si on
continuait comme ça ce programme erasmus
ne seraient plus financées ça fait
évidemment beaucoup de bruit en europe
les télévisions européennes se sont
emparés de ce sujet je vous propose de
regarder ce zapping signé aurélie la
face
9 milliards d'euros
c'est ce qu'il manque pour financer les
programmes d'éducation et en particulier
erasmus la commission s'en inquiètent
fonctionne athlètes délai heureusement
mba state
nous avons donné assez d'argent aux
états membres pour couvrir gelée près de
scolarité jusqu'à la fin 2012 mais pour
le futur nous avons besoin d'un
amendement plus précisément jeu nous
avons besoin de plus d'argent pour
assurer la mise en place de la mobilité
étudiante en 2013 le programme est
populaire même si les coupes budgétaires
menace 3 millions d'étudiants en 25 ans
est une destination favorite au sud de
l'europe l'espagne est le pays qui
reçoit plus de 30 mille étudiants
européens chaque année comme olga qui
vient d'angleterre et mathias du
danemark l'espagne pays attractif mais
pays en crise alors à l' annonce de
cette nouvelle réduction budgétaire les
espagnols sont les premiers européens à
réagir les étudiants erasmus qui arrive
en espagne trouve une éducation avec
encore quelques moyens mais si les
coupes budgétaires continue comme ça il
n'y aura bientôt plus rien sans compter
le climat social très tendu vraiment
défavorables
même si les d'erasmus ne dépasse pas les
160 euros par mois
sans ce coup de pouce certains craignent
qu'à l'avenir ces études ne soit réservé
qu'à une élite
bon alors il reste plus assez l'auberge
espagnole ce film qu'on connaît tous
c'est peut-être ce qui participe
d'ailleurs de la création d'un sentiment
européen chez les jeunes
vous avez fait fort en mettant en avant
le fait que les races plus ce serait
peut-être plus financé bon c'était une
position médiatique j'ai envie est ce
qu'il ya une réelle menace est ce que
erasmus pourrait ne plus avoir d'argent
asmus n'a plus d'argent depuis le 1er
octobre
d'ici la fin de l'année 2012 il n'y a
plus un euro de plus pour ira smooth et
nous sommes en train de négocier avec
les ministres du budget pour faire en
sorte que non seulement sur air à smos
qui est un programme très important pour
l'esprit européen pour la formation des
jeunes comme vous l'avez rappelé mais
qui quantitativement relativement faible
c'est un milliard d'euros sur 130
milliards mais cette absence de crédit
vaut aussi pour des programmes sensibles
en plus important du point de vue du
montant tout le fonds social européen
tout le programme cadre de recherche
européens le fonds de développement
rural et même l'aide humanitaire n'a
plus un rond jusqu'au 31 décembre
et donc il est temps que les
gouvernements c'est ce double langage
dans lequel quand on se réunit au niveau
des grands chefs au conseil européen on
dit il faut soutenir la croissance et en
juin dernier sur la proposition du
président hollande
le conseil européen dit c'est de
consacrer 120 milliards d'euros de
moyens supplémentaires pour soutenir la
croissance trois mois après il ya plus
d'argent pour erasmus pour le fonds
social ont pour l'aide humanitaire
il faut arrêter ce scandale il faut que
les masques tombent nous avons besoin de
ces crédits des engagements étaient pris
des jeunes ont été envoyés faire une
partie de leurs études dans un
l'université d'un pays différent il faut
naturellement que les morceaux pays
alors vous dites y ait plus d'argent
d'erasmus dans tout cas ça concerne pas
tout de suite ça sera peut-être pour
l'année prochaine mais en tout cas pour
les jeunes qui sont déjà partis dans le
cade la flandre on lambour parce que l'
agence installée à bordeaux qui gère le
programme
c'était un peu mes filles avaient vu
venir le coup est assez constituer un
petit matelas
les étudiants français sont pas menacés
mais vous avez entendu dans le reportage
en spy en espagne manifestement il ya
une pénurie de crédit dès maintenant
alors une question sur l'élection
américaine barack obama
vient d'être réélu à la tête des états
unis est ce que c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour l'union européenne c'est une bonne
nouvelle en ce sens qu'on préfère
travailler avec des gens qu'on connaît
ce qu'avec avec ce qu'on ne connaît pas
pendant deux heures et demie ressent pas
des non non on ne peut pas dire que
barack obama était un grand président
américain qu'il était un grand président
sur la scène internationale et on ne
peut pas dire qu'il était un grand ami
de l'europe
cela dit naturellement nous
travaillerons avec lui et je dirais moi
en tant que français la leçon que je
tire de cette élection c'est que la
démagogie d'extrême droite exprimé par
mitt romney n'est pas payante même en
période de crise ça c'est une pédagogie
que je vais faire de mon côté en france
je voudrais en profiter pour dire que la
bonne nouvelle pour les européens sera
peut-être surprendre les téléspectateurs
c'est que la prochaine grande élection
de ce type aura lieu en europe dans
toute l'europe dans 18 mois
nous allons pour la première fois grâce
au dernier traité européen le traité de
lisbonne élire un président du pouvoir
exécutif européen la commission
européenne au suffrage universel lors de
la traverse élections du parlement
européen en juin le parlement européen
sera réélu et cette fois ci le président
de la commission qui jusqu'à présent
était désigné comme on nomme un haut
fonctionnaire international le
secrétaire-général de l'onu ou directeur
général du fmi par un accord entre les
gouvernements le successeur de présent
barroso sera élu par nous tous les 500
millions de citoyens européens et nous
allons assister à des face-à-face
télévisé entre les candidats des deux
grands partis politiques européens
le parti de droite le ppe les
socialistes européens qui s'y prépare
dès maintenant et nous allons j'espère
avoir une véritable autorité politique
avec tables président européen élu au
suffrage universel en 18 mois si les
médias européens consacrent autant de
temps et d'énergie aux élections
européennes qu'elles l'ont fait pour les
élections américaines à l'animation
merci beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
nous allons parler maintenant d'un autre
sujet c'est celui du gaspillage
alimentaire c'est un problème européen
il se trouve qu il ya un pays qui a fait
beaucoup d'efforts là dessus c'est le
royaume uni nous allons partout
ir pour un reportage à londres avec
flora sauvage et ensuite nous irons à
paris retrouvé kathia gilder et son
invité guillaume garot qui est ministre
délégué à l'agroalimentaire et qui nous
présentera le plan français tout de
suite donc direction londres avec laura
sauvage
chaque année en grande bretagne 15
millions de tonnes de nourriture sont
jetés à la poubelle la moitié provient
des ménages steve essai de gaspiller le
moins possible et malgré tout il lui
arrive de gâcher de la nourriture
parfois c'est difficile de s'y retrouver
cette salade par exemple va peut-être
finir à la poubelle mon compost on
congèle le pain pour faire des toasts
parce que c'est difficile de s'y
retrouver sinon depuis quatre ans la
mairie d'arrondissement de steve a mis à
sa disposition une poubelle destinée à
recueillir ses déchets alimentaires
voici mes poubelles
jean ligne pour les déchets une autre
pour le recyclage et une autre pour la
nourriture à la mairie la luge de notre
disposition gratuitement
je peux y mettre tous les déchets
alimentaires légumes fruits viandes
poissons tout y passe l'objectif du
gouvernement britannique est de réduire
le gaspillage alimentaire de 700 mille
tonnes d'ici 2015
car il ya urgence il y a eu un réel
effort au royaume uni pour réduire le
gaspillage alimentaire
on a à peu près la même population qu'en
france nous sommes 63 millions mais le
royaume uni est beaucoup plus petit en
superficie particulièrement à londres où
l'on et 8 millions donc il faut vraiment
qu'on fasse attention car on n'a pas
assez de place pour incinérer nos
déchets
tristram stuart est un fervent militant
contre le gaspillage alimentaire
il organise dans les capitales
européennes des buffets gratuits avec
des ingrédients destinés à être jetés
pour mobiliser les consommateurs sur le
gaspi les consommateurs britanniques
jette environ 20 pour cent de la
nourriture qu'ils à chaque fois un
certain nombre d'initiatives ont été
mises en place pour réduire le
gaspillage dans les foyers des dans
l'industrie ainsi vu une réduction de
13% du gaspillage des ménages ce qui est
plutôt positif
maintenant on met la pression sur
l'industrie car les supermarchés
britanniques produisent trois cent mille
tonnes de déchets alimentaires par an
certains ont pris le problème à bras le
corps et font la chasse au gaspi les
offres promotionnelles sur les produits
qui approche de la date de péremption
ont permis à la chaîne de supermarchés
marks and spencer de réduire son
gaspillage alimentaire de 40% depuis
qu'ils ont mis en place cette initiative
en 2008 d'après tristram stuart un tiers
de la production alimentaire mondiale
est jeté à la poubelle alors même qu'un
milliard d'êtres humains sur la planète
ne mange pas à sa faim à spidah field le
plus vieux marché londonien
neuf restaurants gaspille chaque année
200 mille tonnes de nourriture face à ce
constat
andres felipe ramirez a été engagé par
le centre commercial pour limiter ce
gaspillage
voici l'arrière des restaurants sec 6/10
il ya différentes sections on a des
poubelles exploit pour la nourriture
mais livre ait la principale à la
restauratrice la carie ici c'est la
salade le potentiel du recyclage de la
nourriture est énorme on peut produire
de l'engrais ou de l'électricité
aussi quand la nourriture qu'on jette et
on empêche au passage que ces déchets
des effets toxiques sur l'environnement
dans cette usine du sud de londres on
recycle les déchets alimentaires pour
produire de l'engrais destinés aux
agriculteurs de la région
salade poisson 1/2 les echets collectés
ici viennent des restaurants des
supermarchés ou encore des maisons des
alentours
ces céréales ne sont pas périmés mais
elles ont été jetés à la poubelle
c'est tout à fait mangeable ce produit
se périment l'année prochaine mais il ya
peut-être un problème de bactéries
expliquerait que c'est serré affronter
jeter bien tout simplement peut-être y
at-il un essai audi fait de l'emballage
et le fabricant a préféré tout jeter
plutôt que le consommateur achète un
produit avec un emballage un peu depuis
2002 en grande bretagne la directive de
l'union européenne sur la mise en
décharge des déchets fixe des objectifs
de recyclage et de valorisation
dès lors une réelle prise de conscience
a eu lieu notre moteur principal c'est
la directive européenne sur les déchets
malheureusement elle est loin
d'approcher les objectifs que la
directive nous impose
on risque donc d'avoir une amende de
l'union européenne si on ne parvient pas
à réaliser ses objectifs et les denrées
alimentaires sont l'une des choses les
plus faciles à recycler
près de la moitié des aliments encore
sains sont gaspillées chaque année par
les ménages et les supermarchés de
l'union européenne alors que 79 millions
d'européens vivent au dessous du seuil
de pauvreté
l'objectif de l'union européenne est de
réduire son gaspillage alimentaire de
50% d'ici à 2025
bonjour monsieur le ministre jo merci de
nous recevoir
in situ dans votre bureau à paris pour
cette émission d'europe hebdo consacré
au gaspillage alimentaire alors on peut
citer ce chiffre impressionnant plus
d'un tiers de la production alimentaire
mondiale serait jetée à la poubelle
alors qu'un milliard d'êtres humains ne
mange pas à sa faim
en europe aussi on gaspille beaucoup
outre-manche nos amis britanniques ont
trouvé quelques solutions et le
gouvernement veut réduire le gaspillage
de 700 mille tonnes d'ici 2015 la grande
bretagne at elle une en avance sur la
france
en tout cas il ya des pays européens qui
aujourd'hui vont de l'avant et la france
veut être dans ce train de tête parce
que chacun de nous aujourd'hui en france
jettent de 20 à 30 kg de nourriture
chaque année c'est d'abord une perte de
pouvoir d'achat
ce sont des euros qu'on met à la
poubelle et on l'a évalué à peu près 500
euros par année pour une famille de
quatre personnes dont il ya d'abord un
enjeu économique
et puis il ya aussi un enjeu de valeur
parce que vous l'avez dit au moment où
tant d'êtres humains grève de la faim ou
dépendent de l'aide alimentaire
eh bien il faut s'engager concrètement
pour lutter contre les dérives de la
société de surconsommation c'est ce que
nous faisons
alors vous proposer un pacte national
anti gaspillage
si vous en donner les grandes lignes qui
qui cible et vous en priorité le
consommateur ou plutôt la grande
distribution s'agit de cibler personne
mais d'engager chacun ça veut dire que
aujourd'hui si nous voulons concrètement
efficacement lutter contre le gaspillage
alimentaire il faut que chacun s'engage
chacun sait qui en est fait
les citoyens les consommateurs mais ce
sont aussi tous les acteurs de la chaîne
alimentaire des producteurs jusqu'aux
distributeurs en passant par les
transformateurs
sans oublier les associations de
solidarité qui joue un grand rôle pour
lutter contre ce gaspillage
est ce que tous ces acteurs sont prêts à
entendre vos arguments je crois mais
santé mobiliser derrière je crois je les
rencontre depuis que j'ai engagé cette
initiative contre le gaspillage et il ya
une vraie volonté de faire mouvement
ensemble et c'est la condition de la
réussite que ensemble nous affichions
des objectifs et que ensemble nous
agissions donc c'est ça l'idée de ce
pacte c'est d'engager des actions
concrètes alors concrètes ça veut dire
dans la restauration collective par
exemple et avec le conseil général de la
dordogne nous allons faire en sorte que
dans les collèges on puisse réduire le
gaspillage alimentaire donc oui il ya
une dimension éducative avec les enfants
mais on va aussi travailler en mayenne
dans mon département pour que avec un
foyer de restauration collective pour
pour adultes pour jeunes adultes on
puisse là aussi adapter les besoins aux
pauvres et portion aux justes
proportions
voilà ce qui compte aujourd'hui alors ça
c'est une zone test si j'ai bien compris
et quel calendrier de l'application de
ces mesures de ce que vous allez mettre
en place en dordogne par exemple
toutes ces actions sont lancés au fur et
à mesure elles seront évaluées au
printemps prochain au mois d'avril et au
mois de juin nous signerons ce pacte
national contre le gaspillage
alimentaire avec l'ensemble des acteurs
le pourquoi cette démarche progressive
parce que il faut créer une dynamique et
une dynamique collective contre le
gaspillage alors j'ai parlé de la
restauration collective
nous pourrions parler aussi des marchés
d'intérêt national vous savez là où
comme à rungis les producteurs viennent
vendre leurs
leur production est bien avec les
associations de solidarité nous allons
récupérer les invendus pour les
retraités immédiatement dans l'aide
alimentaire là aussi une façon concrète
de lutter contre le gaspillage donc au
fur et à mesure tous les acteurs que
j'ai cités seront mobilisés et au mois
de juin ce sera cette réunion nationale
contre le gaspillage alimentaire pour
revenir à la grande distribution
quels moyens avez-vous concrètement de
leur faire appliquer ce pacte alors même
que certaines enseignes peuvent inciter
les consommateurs à acheter en grande
quantité vu qu'il ya souvent des offres
promotionnelles des choses comme ça dit
un vrai levier d'action vous avez raison
et vous savez que la grande distribution
est aujourd'hui mobilisée dans ce pacte
national futur pacte national contre le
gaspillage alors concrètement quelle
forme ça peut prendre d'abord ça peut
être la vente à l'unité en particulier
pour les produits laitiers c'est ce
qu'on cite le plus souvent aujourd'hui
un tiers des français vivent seuls donc
il faut aussi adapter l'offre dans les
magasins la réalité de la consommation
donc là dessus nous allons avancer avec
certaines grandes marques de la
distribution et puis nous allons
travailler aussi c'est une idée qui
avait été lancé d'ailleurs par nos amis
anglais à ce qu'on appelle les
promotions différé ça veut dire que pour
trois produits payés au prix de 2 et
bien vous prenez la première semaine les
deux premiers produits et puis vous avez
le troisième la semaine suivante ce qui
vous évite de gaspiller
donc voyez concrètement petit à petit
mais avec beaucoup de détermination nous
allons pouvoir lutter contre le
gaspillage
moi j'ai fixé un objectif ambitieux
c'est celui qui a indiqué d'ailleurs le
parlement européen de réduire de moitié
le gaspillage alimentaire en france
d'ici 2025
alors justement comment se situe la
france par rapport à ses autres
partenaires actuellement avant la mise
en oeuvre de votre plan plutôt bon ou
mauvais élèves nous sommes plutôt bon
élève par rapport à d'autres pays
européen nous sommes plutôt bien placé
mais là encore nous avons des marges de
progression
1 et si nous pouvons améliorer les
choses nous le ferons c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai proposé cet objectif
ambitieux pour 2025 mais nous serons
d'autant plus efficace que partout en
europe il y aura ce mouvement contre le
gaspillage alimentaire et là où c'est
intéressant c'est que ça n'est pas
simplement les politiques qu'ils se
saisissent du dossier on voit bien
partout des associations des citoyens se
mobiliser pour dire maintenant on arrête
le gaspillage
on y va et bien tous ensemble à lyon xi
alors en grande bretagne tristram stuart
à et partir en guerre contre contre le
gaspillage
il dit que book que beaucoup de
gouvernements européens l'ont sollicité
pour trouver des solutions à ce que vous
êtes entré en contact aussi avec les ce
que vous l'avez rencontré bien ça fait
partie des rendez vous que je veux
savoir pour finaliser l'ensemble
des actions mais d'ores et déjà ce qui
vaut pour moi c'est aussi de repérer
partout sur le territoire national ces
initiatives qui existent et qui
permettent de lutter jour après jour
contre le gaspillage voulait mettre en
valeur de les mettre en lumière de telle
sorte que ce qui se fait de bien aussi
sur nos territoires en france puissent
être reproduits généralisée ailleurs ça
passe aussi par une mobilisation de
chaque citoyen comme vous et moi avec
par exemple une modification des
pratiques consommé au jour le jour
plutôt que d'acheter en grande quantité
avec le risque de jeter c'est aussi des
actions comme ça qui bien sûr faire
beaucoup bien sûr puisque chacun il est
prêt finalement et pour ça nous avons
nous voulu simplifier faciliter la vie
des citoyens nous avons créé un site un
site sur lequel vous pouvez vous rendre
avec des initiatives des bonnes idées
qui permettent tout simplement de mieux
gérer son réfrigérateur et essaie des
choses simples mais pas des choses
simples et bien on y arrive et si la
mobilisation est collective elle sera
d'autant plus efficace
donc c'est le sens aussi de ce site que
je veux très participatif gaspillage
alimentaire point fr c'est ça le nom du
site avec notamment une campagne virale
qui démarre à assez fort ça de
l'amusante qui est pas culpabilisante
mais qui est fait pour pour appeler
chacun à cette prise de conscience
1 c'est très important et puis qui
montre que ne pas gaspiller c'est pas
être triste au contraire c'est une
nouvelle façon d'être de consommer c'est
pas moins acheté moins consommer c'est
mieux acheter mieux consommer c'est fait
avec beaucoup d'humour
c'est vrai eh bien merci beaucoup
monsieur mairie ou de nous avoir reçus
chez vous à paris merci à vous de votre
fidélité on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour d'autres actualités
européenne passé une très bonne semaine
sur les chaînes parlementaires